like you hear a lot of stories
by the way was Johnny Depp a nice guy
back then such a nice guy he was I'm
sure he's a nice guy now did you think
he was going to be a big movie star
honestly no way I didn't I mean because
I didn't tell if I could not tell if he
liked acting or not because he seemed
kind of tortured by it the pressure of I
know that he really worked hard to be
you know Glenn and he worked very hard
on his part and so I couldn't tell if he
was enjoying himself frankly I mean
because he was always so very dedicated
serious and he just didn't have that ego
at all so you didn't really you didn't
draw draw your attention to him that him
himself that way whereas you know I had
seen other actors like I'd been around
Matt Dylan and I'd been around you know
some of those Brat Pack guys and they
all had this look at me I'm so hot you
know they had they had that confidence
because they'd all become incredibly
Successful by then and Johnny didn't
have that he was still like kind of
finding his place and